aux côtés de magali païens et de marion
cotillard le réalisateur cyril dion a
lancé à cannes une nouvelle société de
production nommée new topia l'objectif
racontait de nouvelles histoires pour
changer l'image que l'on peut avoir du
futur et pour mettre en avant les enjeux
environnementaux
on trouve que la plupart des films
aujourd'hui ont une vision soit très
apocalyptique du futur soit très
dystopique au sens et les robots les
extraterrestres l'intelligence
artificielle et qui a pas d'histoire
d'une certaine manière qui nous aident à
imaginer le monde dans lequel on
aimerait vivant on est en train de lever
des fonds pour que avec cette société de
production et en s'associant avec tout
un autre écosystème de producteurs on
puisse chaque année produire 5 10 films
séries qui
- qui dynamite un peu les imaginaires
pour l avenir quel rôle peut jouer le
cinéma dans la lutte contre le
réchauffement climatique le festival de
cannes avait l'année dernière place et
le festival sous le signe de
l'environnement de plus à partir de
l'année prochaine tous les films qui
seront soutenus par le centre national
de la cinématographie devront
obligatoirement fournir un bilan carbone
pour cyril dion le cinéma est un moyen
de changer le monde le cinéma a un
impact considérable sur la sur
l'imaginaire des gens et donc sur la
façon dont la société s'organise si on
regarde par exemple comment le
l'american way of life s'est développée
après la deuxième guerre mondiale c'est
clairement à travers le cinéma donc une
arme de wind de suggestions massive sur
la façon dont on peut se déplacer manger
fumer
dépenses et
là on en est à un moment où on a besoin
d'eux d'avoir la même bascule que ce qui
a eu après la deuxième guerre mondiale
mais dans le sens de l'écologie donc là
aussi le cinéma peut avoir un impact
considérable pour y parvenir une arme
qu'il compte bien utiliser son prochain
film sera l'adaptation du livre de
pierre de crozet le grand vertige un
roman d'aventurés sur le changement
climatique
mais il faudra attendre encore un peu
pour le voir sur les écrans cyril dit on
en est pour l'instant qu'au scénario